[Music]
on this Wednesday night the coronavirus
officially reaches pandemic proportions
what it means and what it calls for this
is a call to action and a call not to
give up as more countries including
Canada make plans to act we will make
sure you have everything you need our
Canadian hospitals equipped to cope as
the Health Minister spells out the worst
case scenario it's safe to assume that
it could be between 30% and 70% of the
population social distancing what you
need to know about keeping your distance
slowing the spread and flattening the
curve of infections and from producer to
prisoner a sentence for convicted rapist
Harvey Weinstein
global national with Donna freezin
good evening and thanks for joining us
the World Health Organization has now
confirmed what many epidemiologists have
been saying for weeks
the corona virus is a pandemic there are
now more than 120,000 known cases in 114
countries but it's not the word pandemic
we should focus on says the w-h-o it's
preparation public health and political
leadership because all experts agree
this is going to get worse the dangers
of using a word if people use it as an
excuse to give up or if people see it as
something that grows fear it is not the
time for countries to move towards
mitigation only unless and until they
are not in a position to affect the
course of the epidemic and try and stop
this organism the difficulty is that if
you do not try and suppress this virus
it can overwhelm your health system in
Canada there are now more than 110 known
cases of kovat 19 including a doctor in
Ontario who treats cancer patients and
today for the first time the Health
Minister gave an estimate of the number
of people in this country who could
become infected I would say that it's
safe to assume that it could be between
30% of the population that acquire the
Cova 19 and 70% of the population this
seems to be an acceptable range I
realize it's a large range but that is
actually what what is our best guess
Prime Minister Justin Trudeau announced
a 1 billion dollar response fund today
it includes money to buy health supplies
and to support people who have to stay
home from work more on that in just a
moment in Italy where cases are still
spiking there are drastic new
restrictions tonight the Prime Minister
has ordered all businesses to shut down
except grocery stores and pharmacies the
number of cases is growing quickly in
Spain France Germany and the UK tonight
Hungary has declared a state of
emergency and India today put tight
border controls in place and cancelled
all tourists and business visas Christel
commencing on the global response to
this pandemic my right honourable friend
the health secretary is working around
the clock to protect the public from the
UK to Germany to vatican city leaders
are addressing the rapid spread of the
new coronavirus and its impact on health
and daily life the Bank of England's
actions today comprise a timely and
powerful package to support UK
businesses and households in order to
bridge a temporarily difficult period
the lending rate reduced back to its
record low of one quarter on budget day
is a bit of financial comfort we saw a
large chunk of the budget earmarked for
that purpose 12 billion pounds set aside
to help with the economy with businesses
and of course the fact that so many
people potentially a fifth of the
workforce could at some point be off
because of the virus the German
Chancellor also warning of hard times
ahead
community saying the population has no
immunity and no therapy exists then 60
to 70 percent of the population will be
infected
it took Connor Reed a British man who
lives in Wuhan China about a month to
recover from cope at 19 it's not like
that you only use soft my lung capacity
and every breath I thought wasn't enough
and I just couldn't get enough also it
sounded like I was really threw a paper
bag Italy's health system is overrun
roughly 900 people are in critical care
according to the World Health
Organization's dr. Mike Ryan the fact is
right now in countries we have frontline
health workers who need our help we have
hospitals who need our support
we have people who need our care and we
need to focus on getting our frontline
health workers the equipment supplies
and training they need to do a good job
while countries such as Italy and Iran
are in the middle of the battle
elsewhere the impact of kovat 19 is just
beginning
crystal the Manson Global News London
here's where we're at with confirmed
cases in Canada there are 46 in BC where
a man died at a nursing home two of the
new cases there are health care workers
from that home there are 41
cases in Ontario 19 in Alberta 4 in
Quebec and New Brunswick now has a
presumptive case of kovat 19 the first
in Atlantic Canada of greatest concern
is a doctor in Ontario and oncologist at
Hamilton health sciences the woman in
her 30s tested positive after traveling
from Hawaii on Saturday she treated 14
cancer patients on Monday
shortly before getting the positive
tests she plus 5 staff who work in the
clinic and three other doctors are now
in self-isolation and one of the
passengers from the Grand Princess
cruise ship has tested positive the
person is among the 228 passengers under
quarantine at CFB Trenton they had past
initial screening in California but this
person had a mild fever and cough when
they got to Trenton and are now being
kept separate from other passengers
today the federal government ramped up
its response announcing a billion dollar
package of new measures David akin
explains what the money will be spent on
David well half of the new billion
dollar fund is earmarked for the
provinces money that can be used to buy
health care equipment or support
mitigation efforts another 275 million
will be spent on vaccine and other kovat
19 research the rest is for indigenous
communities and for public health
authorities we are pulling out all the
stops to make sure Canadians stay safe
healthy and supported the federal
government is also waiving the one week
waiting period for employment insurance
benefits and that means anyone who has
to stay home from work can qualify for
immediate EEI assistance employers can
use enhanced work sharing programs no
one should have to worry about their job
if they have to be quarantined no
employer should feel like they have to
lay off a worker because of the virus we
can support you and we will but critics
say more could be done what's missing in
that plan is any way to help out workers
who want to stay home from work because
they're not feeling well and don't have
access to e aí we certainly think that
there's still a lot of unanswered
questions that two Canadians will have
not only about this package but about
the the entire Crona virus and and what
it's what
means four Canadians now Trudeau also
said that even though Canada has been
relatively lucky so far
federal and provincial health
authorities are preparing for the worst
for a sharp spike in Canadian cases
Donna and David we're hearing from
multiple public health experts that we
need to undertake serious mitigation now
meaning reorganizing our lives to limit
who we come in contact with did the
Prime Minister talk about that boy he
was asked a lot about that today but
right now the Trudeau government has no
intention of restricting freedom of
movement or restricting gatherings
instead Trudeau expects Canadians to
voluntarily make those small changes to
their daily lives to keep their families
and their communities safe
Ottawa also has no plans to ban
travelers coming from kovat 19 hotspots
like China or northern Italy but Trudeau
did say this he said the government will
soon have some new rules for cruise
ships that dock at Canadian ports
that'll come in the coming days Donna
okay David akin and Ottawa Thanks
Washington State has announced strict
new controls today the governor says
there could be 64,000 cases in that
state if nothing is done so he has
ordered a ban on parades concerts
festivals and other gatherings of 250 or
more people in the Seattle area where
there's being an outbreak the US has
been slow to test in many places the
president has told people not to worry
but today a top American public health
expert made it clear things will get
worse how bad it gets depends on how we
respond now if we wait till we have many
many more cases we will be multiple
weeks behind the Wayne Gretzky approach
you know you skate not to where the puck
is but to where the puck is going to be
if we don't do very serious mitigation
now
that what's gonna happen is that we're
gonna be weeks behind and the horse is
going to be out of the barn and that's
the reason why we've been saying even in
areas of the country where there are no
or few cases we've got to change our
behavior we have to essentially assume
that we are gonna get hit
people ask why would you want to make
any mitigation we don't have any cases
that's when you do it if cases in Canada
do start to spike like they have
elsewhere Canadian hospitals will
struggle they're already operating over
capacity in some communities emergency
rooms have even closed so what is being
done to prepare Heather Eurex West is
looking into that for us tonight in
Calgary new assessment centers for
suspected cases of kovat 19 are now in
operation they're a part of the
provinces pandemic plan aimed at keeping
infectious patients away from the ER
instead those patients have been asked
to call ahead but across the country
telehealth lines have been struggling to
keep up with demand
we shouldn't conflate or confuse being
prepared with being perfect so we are
seeing issues pop up and as we see those
issues we're addressing them right now
the pressure is on provincial labs and
those working to track assess and test
for the virus they know that if efforts
to contain kovat 19 fail patient demand
on hospitals will soar it is important
to prepare for a range of different
scenarios but of course it's sensible to
prepare for something worse than prepare
for something that's mild a worst case
scenario could see hundreds of thousands
even millions of additional patients
requiring critical care far more than
existing intensive care units can handle
in many cases our hospitals are working
at operating at a hundred and twenty
percent capacity they are really
concerned as to what the kovat
19 will do to the system in Montreal
this shuttered Hospital has reopened for
just that purpose focus now on
assessment the facility treated twenty
patients on its first day but it's not
just space that's required for koban
nineteenth most critical ventilators are
the difference between life and death
the federal government says it's working
to procure additional supplies but
admits that around the world supplies
are becoming tight we need to look at
where where the materials are and how we
could have access to these materials and
maybe put production in place to to
increase the amount of supplies and
material undeniably now the road ahead
will be tough
pandemic plans in place this is no
longer a drill Heather your exbest
global news Calgary well we know you
have lots of questions about this virus
starting tomorrow we will answer some of
them are Geoff simple has consulted
experts and will join us and you can
send your questions to your questions
at global news CA on our website you'll
also find a special page dedicated
entirely to the new corona virus that's
at Global News CA / coronavirus Joe
Biden sweeps another Super Tuesday
coming up how his rival Bernie Sanders
is reacting Plus why Harvey Weinstein's
lawyers call his prison sentence obscene
Harvey Weinstein's accusers they
celebrated today he was sentenced to 23
years in prison for rape and sexual
assaults his lawyers had asked for five
years Weinstein was convicted last month
for sex crimes against two women both of
whom worked in the film industry he's
been accused of many more lawyers for
the 67 year old call a sentence obscene
and plan to appeal his conviction Joe
Biden has cemented his position as the
frontrunner for the Democratic Party's
nominee to face President Trump
six more states went to the polls
yesterday and most of them were won by
the former vice president as Abigail
Beeman reports his sole opponent Bernie
Sanders is not backing down Paul it's
Super Tuesday too for Joe Biden we are a
step closer to restoring decency dignity
and honor to the White House he swept at
least four of six states including
battleground Michigan a huge blow to
Bernie Sanders who won in 2016 and
prides himself on connecting with
blue-collar and young voters the race is
over Bernie Sanders cannot catch up
he's been dependent on younger voters
and younger voters are doing what they
have done since time immemorial in this
country which is they're not showing up
Biden offered a message of unity Tuesday
night I want to thank Bernie Sanders and
his supporters for their tireless energy
and their passion we share a common goal
and together we'll defeat Donald Trump
Sanders waited until Wednesday to speak
and amid some calls for him to step
aside he's still in the race it is not
just the ideological debate that our
progressive movement is winning we are
winning the generational debate it's
gonna be important for us to unify if we
are going to defeat Donald Trump
Elena Beverly was the deputy director
for urban affairs in the Obama White
House she says no matter who becomes the
nominee they'll need to bring more
voters into the tent and it's an open
question whether Sanders won the
ideological debate as he claims it still
remains to be seen how the Democratic
electorate
to address issues like Medicare for all
healthcare and whether or not there
should be a single-payer system
Tuesday's results make it very difficult
for Sanders to come back now all eyes
will be on the next debate on Sunday in
a very narrow field for the first time
it will just be Sanders and Biden facing
off on stage abigail Beeman Global News
Washington
ahead the push for more government
spending on rail travel
we've been looking at rail service this
week and tonight we examine how viable
passenger rail service is in this
country the federal government is on the
verge of making a multi-billion dollar
commitment to passenger rail as megan
robinson reports it has a poor track
record of rail investment traveling from
Toronto to Montreal on via rail used to
be faster when I started in McGill in
2002 you could get to Montreal in under
four hours if you took the fastest train
and that's not an option anymore the
same trip today takes at least 50
minutes longer and that's after Via Rail
spent over 300 million dollars to make
it faster in 2016 the auditor-general
revealed the money wasn't enough to
resolve what Via Rail describes as an
underlying problem most of the tracks
are owned by CN which said passenger
service has improved and while it
continues working with Via Rail it's not
clear what kind of deal the two
companies have signed we're not privy to
those details fine so much of the train
service agreement between Via Rail and
CN is covered by commercial
confidentiality Via Rail is considering
a solution called high frequency rail
the initial cost for the project would
be four point four billion dollars for
Canadian taxpayers it would mean more
reliable trains and dedicated tracks
between Toronto and Quebec City but they
haven't agreed how to share access with
local transit agencies in Toronto and
Montreal and this could drive up costs a
key question about HSR and we have not
had this question answered is is this
the cheapest way to do it or is there a
way to do it on the existing corridor
with political will documents obtained
by Global News break down the 4.4
billion dollar plan 2.1 billion for work
from Toronto to Ottawa ninety one and a
half million between Ottawa and Montreal
and 1.1 four billion for a new route
between Montreal Quebec City plus
another 1.1 billion for a new fleet of
trains the rails maintenance crews have
been working absolute miracles to keep
the stuff going as long as they have
and if the governor is serious about
tackling climate change and about giving
people options that use less carbon
while maintaining quality of life
passenger rail and intercity bus
services absolutely central to that the
union representing via rail workers also
wants new legislation for passenger rail
to give it some priority over freight
traffic but the government tells us it's
not considering legislative changes if
the government isn't prepared to invest
in actually creating the network for Via
Rail then there has to be something in
place that will support passenger
service and allow Via Rail a priority on
freight lines in order to meet our
mandate if the high frequency rail
project is a success experts say it
could revitalize passenger trains in
Canada if we want people to travel by
train in stiphu the easiest cheapest
fastest option Via Rail has now hired
consultants to deliver recommendations
on the final route between Toronto and
Quebec City before the end of the month
they'll also examine how much it would
cost to make the new trains electric
megan robinson global news toronto
keeping your distance next how to act in
the midst of a pandemic
it's a big event in figure skating and
it's just been canceled the world
championships in Montreal won't take
place next week concern about the spread
of the corona virus put it on the
growing list of major events being
postponed or canceled measures like that
though they seem extreme are what's
required to slow the spread and slowing
the virus is as important as stopping it
here's why carry on as usual do nothing
to limit the spread and the curve of
cases rapidly goes up stretching health
care capacity put in place measures like
testing self isolation and social
distancing and the virus will still
spread but more slowly so doctors and
hospitals aren't so overwhelmed it's
called flattening the curve it's what
specialists and infectious disease say
has to happen right now Micro la
explains how everyday life is changing
we made the decision not to have a
studio audience a proactive approach to
kovat 19 containment in north america
the TV show the view tape before an
empty audience Wednesday an example of
what's called a social distancing but
that case was volunteer Washington State
has made it illegal for crowds larger
than 250 people to gather it's 1,000 in
San Francisco which will see the Golden
State Warriors play in an empty arena
Thursday the idea is people can move
about freely
they just can't gather in large numbers
so if you have a one-on-one interaction
with somebody the chances of
transmission is low with but if you have
a 1 in 1 transmission you know
multiplied 10,000 times you're likely to
transmission now goes up it all it takes
is a few individuals who have the virus
all of a sudden for you to have a few
transmission events and those so then
the virus just kind of explodes from
there
history has shown social distancing to
work provided it's put into effect
before the virus is time to spread in
1918 facing the threat of the Spanish
flu Philadelphia's health commissioner
was urged to cancel a large parade he
didn't and thousands died at the same
time st. Louis's health commissioner
shut his City down preventing what could
have been another tragedy we would
recommend that there not be law
crowds if that means not having any
people in the audience or the NBA plays
so be it but as a public health official
anything that has large crowds is
something that would give a risk to
spread so what do we do here
health experts warned it won't take much
for the virus to spread as it has in
Italy or worse and China the man Pearl
Jam has postponed its North American
tour but that was a decision they made
the Canadian federal government is
leaving those decisions up the provinces
and event organizers but nobody it's
clear wants to be the one to cancel
sporting events or concerts or close
schools the economic impact will be huge
but what's plan B microlight Global News
Toronto and that is global national for
this Wednesday I'm Donna Friesen
tonight's chair of Canada is near Coburg
Ontario we'd love to see your Canada
please email it to viewers at global
national comm thanks for watching and
hope to see you here again tomorrow
bye bye
[Music]
me